[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka guten abend
der ukrainische präsident spricht von
einer schicksals schlacht in der stadt
suchodolsk werde sich das schicksal des
ganzen dorfes entscheiden sagte selent
ski wie sehr russland wie sehr putin
dort den erfolg sucht zeigt sich auch
daran dass er seine truppen häuserkämpfe
schickt straße um straße haus um haus
begleitet von massiven bombardements wie
sich das kriegsgeschehen dort im
einzelnen darstellt lässt sich von außen
allerdings kaum sagen und es bleibt
natürlich auch die frage wie sich
russland einen sieg vorstellt anstatt zu
erobern ist das eine als besatzer ganze
region dauerhaft zu beherrschen etwas
anderes christiane hofmann fasst
zusammen welche informationen und bilder
und heute erreichten
seit wochen suchen die menschen im
donbass schutz in solchen kellern vor
raketen und bomben nur das nötigste um
zu überleben haben sie dabei es sind vor
allem die alten und kranken die im ort
solle da zurückgeblieben sind
wir sind fast die ganze zeit im keller
unser zuhause ist in der nähe aber wir
werden hier tag und nacht nur
kurz trauen sich die menschen in den
feuerpausen raus sehen dann krater und
zerstörung doch die die noch da sind
wollen oder können nicht weg so wartet
jemand auf mich nirgendwo die was mache
ich mit meiner mutter sie ist schon 85
jahre alt und geht nicht mehr raus die
heftigsten kämpfe toben derzeit um die
stadt hier werden jetzt einer der
letzten orte der region lohans der von
den russen noch nicht eingenommen wurde
was wirklich vor sich geht ist schwer zu
sagen es gibt kaum bilder und
informationen ein häuserkampf es heißt
die russen hätten die stadt fast
eingenommen und die ukraine verdrängt
später beide seiten hätten sich
zurückgezogen der bürgermeister spricht
von zehntausenden zivilisten die noch in
der stadt festsitzen sie raus zu bringen
sei nicht mehr möglich
der gouverneur von lohans gefordert im
zdf-interview den westen auf weiter
waffen zu liefern
geben sie uns mehrfach raketenwerfer mit
reichweite damit wir die russische
artillerie ausschalten können und unsere
soldaten werden es dann schon selbst
richten das schicksal des bombers
entscheide sich jetzt in silver dawn
netz erklärte der ukrainische präsident
in einer videobotschaft er sprach auch
über die zukunft nämlich die ukrainische
bewerbung um einen eu-beitritt darüber
habe er auch mit bundeskanzler scholz
gesprochen es geht auch um ihre zukunft
die der schulabsolventen in haag in den
ruinen einer schule tanzen sie zu einem
kriegs lied in dem es heißt ihr zerbombt
unser glück und unsere träume doch ihr
könnt nicht unsere freiheit zerstören
[Musik]
janitos und zugeschaltete ukrainische
minister für regionale entwicklung und
der sonderbeauftragte des ukrainischen
präsidenten für die eu
beitrittsperspektive guten abend nach
düsseldorf
sie haben viele gespräche jetzt in
berlin und düsseldorf geführt und sind
hoffnungsvoll dass ist eine eu
beitrittsperspektive gibt dass die
ukraine beitrittskandidat ende juni wird
beim eu gipfel aber danach kannst dann
ja noch ewig dauern mag sagt es schon
das kann jahrzehnte dauern bis die
ukraine tatsächlich in die eu kommt
ist ja schon ein mitglied der
europäischen familie zeigen dass er
einigen jahren wir haben ein
assoziierungsabkommen mit der eu
2014 abgeschlossen
und wir haben eine ganze reihe getan um
mit den bestand übereinstimmung zu
kommen um den kandidatenstatus zu
bekommen wir erwarten dass der ende juni
kommt am 24
juni und für hoffen und ich würde dann
ganz gerne sofort dann
über unsere erwartungen und die ukraine
erwartet keine hinter die für ein
beschleunigtes verfahren ich denke die
ukraine wird die europäische union durch
die geschwindigkeit und das engagement
überraschen wir all die erforderlichen
kriterien zu erfüllen
oben dann auch entsprechend mitglied der
eu zu werden einige eu-staaten sind
vielleicht auch deshalb etwas zugelegt
weil die ukraine ein
korruptionsproblem hat ein problem mit
einer ost oligarchische strukturierten
wirtschaft das ist natürlich jetzt durch
diesen furchtbaren krieg im hintergrund
getreten aber in dem moment wo es dann
darum geht diese hunderttausend
textseiten eu gesetze zu erfüllen wird
das wieder eine große rolle spielen oder
jetzt absolut loyal finke ja natürlich
wir müssen daran denken dass die ukraine
sich ändert und der krieg hat die
ukraine signifikant verändert die
menschen in der ukraine werden die
korruption nicht mehr tolerieren bei
keinem regierung ist offiziell als und
angesichts der wut und der ukrainische
narration
ganz ganz wichtig und die rheiner werden
so etwas nicht mehr
akzeptieren und darüber hinaus möchte
ich sagen solche leute muss klartext ist
in oregon position gibt es ja auch in
anderen ländern und es geht ja darum das
problem anzugehen und using und die
korruptions signifikant zu reduzieren
eine der gründe warum auch der
westbalkan bislang nicht so richtig
vorangekommen ist mit der eu
beitrittsperspektive manche partner
schon seit fast 20 jahren verstehen sie
wenn der deutsche bundeskanzler sagt wir
müssen aufpassen dass die sich dann auf
dem balkan nicht kopiert fühlen wenn es
dann der ukraine viel schneller gelingt
in die eu zu kommen
das konzept der euro
ist ja dass man überhaupt von der türen
für ein land das europäische werte teilt
und dass deswegen wiederaufbau und
entwicklung dadurch fünf will und
strukturelle reformen durchführen will
und auf dieser perspektive wollen wir
nicht im wege anderer länder stehen
ist das seit jetzt die ukraine zu auf
aufzunehmen und den kandidatenstatus
jetzt zu vergeben ein punkt über den die
eu jetzt auch schon nachdenkt ist jemand
der ukraine beim wiederaufbau helfen
kann und wenn man hier in deutschland
die bilder sieht von diesen unfassbaren
zerstörungen und während gleichzeitig
auch noch bomben fallen und gestorben
wird und und blut vergossen wird kann
man dann trotzdem schon wieder aufbauen
piercings des staates geringe die wir
schon begonnen haben
sobald die repariert haben müssten wir
natürlich auch
unterbringen und für die menschen wohnen
und bauen und wir kommen ist wird die
zentralheizung und die
elektrizitätsversorgung wieder aufbauen
die jetzt sehr stark bombardiert worden
ist auch schon werden die der
kriegszeiten später werden wir dann
weiter machen mit den dringlichen
wiederaufbauarbeiten und nach gegenteil
wir natürlich auch strategische
innovationen und in der aufbauarbeit
würden mit aller art von marshall plant
den wir definitiv mit der eu zusammen
machen werden ich hoffe ich danke ihm
sehr für das gespräch
bringt hier würden wir uns schuldig
ihnen
das inter wir haben ja am frühen abend
aufgezeichnet die europäische union will
jedenfalls beim wiederaufbau der ukraine
eine führende rolle spielen und bei der
frage wie das finanziert wird soll der
verursacher also russland mit
herangezogen werden die eu kommission
will dafür auch an die vermögen der
russischen oligarchen ran das ist
natürlich auch populär mit all den
yachten willen das trifft das
gerechtigkeitsgefühl vieler wenn leute
die sich am zusammenbruch der
sowjetunion bereicherten und später von
putins mafiösen system profitierten und
diese leute nun zahlen müssen für die
zerstörungen die ihr land anrichtet aber
in der praxis ist es dann doch nicht so
einfach berichtet anna klinik
schon wieder eine oligarchen yacht mit
der europa ziemlich wenig anfangen kann
über ein dutzend der schwimmenden
paläste sind inzwischen in eu häfen
festgesetzt in palma de mallorca
durchsucht die spanische polizei im
april die tango ein shift aus dem
russischen milliardär viktor wechselberg
gehören soll auf ersuchen der usa dort
steht er schon länger auf der
sanktionsliste die amerikaner
beschlagnahmen das vermögen russischer
oligarchen auf der ganzen welt anders in
europa die superyachten superreicher
russen werden zwar festgehalten aber
nicht enteignet noch nicht
wenn wir alle bitten zum wiederaufbau
der ukraine beizutragen dann ist es
einfach eine frage der gerechtigkeit
dass auch russland beteiligt wird und
dass wir uns anschauen die eingefrorenen
finanzmittel der oligarchen oder
russlands selber das ist nicht einfach
das haben auch die eu-justizminister
begriffen europa steht für
rechtsstaatlichkeit privatvermögen zu
konfiszieren das geht nur unter
strengsten auflagen
bei privaten gibt es die möglichkeit
auch vermögensgegenstände abzuschöpfen
das instrument kennen wir in deutschland
das setzt aber voraus dass ihnen dann im
wege auch eines ordentlichen
gerichtsverfahrens nachgewiesen wurde
dass sie
beispielsweise kriegsverbrechen oder der
illegalen kriegsführung beteiligt waren
also versucht es die eu kommission mit
einer art trick sie will auch die
umgehung von sanktionen also das
verschieben und verschleiern von
vermögen in allen eu ländern zu einer
straftat machen darin so der
justizkommissar sein sich fast alle
einig
nicht sagen dass alle einstimmig dafür
sind es gibt noch ein paar technische
fragen die mit bestimmten prozeduren in
dem ländern zu tun haben eine davon ist
dass bundestag und europaparlament einem
solchen gesetz noch zustimmen müssten
das kann dauern
unterdessen hat der milliardenschwere
russische unternehmer roman abramowitsch
seine yacht solaris aus barcelona ins
nicht eu land türkei verlegt und
angekündigt dass er die eu sanktionen
vom europäischen gerichtshof anfechten
werde
wie einig oder uneinig der westen
gegenüber russland ist darüber
diskutiert nachher maybrit illner mit
ihren gästen im anschluss ans heute
journal und natürlich finden sie viele
berichte und hintergründe zu diesem
krieg online auf zdf heute mit dem thema
wie das jetzt auch in den nachrichten
erst mal weiterhin ja der krieg
russlands gegen die ukraine war auch ein
thema von bundeskanzler scholz bei
seinem besuch der digital konferenz re
publica heute in berlin scholz warf
russland imperialismus vor und sagte
dieser werde niemals akzeptiert daher
die sanktionen gegen russland und die
unterstützung der ukraine wirtschaftlich
finanziell humanitär und auch
militärisch
nach der tödlichen amokfahrt in berlin
mit einer toten und mehr als 30
verletzten soll der fahrer in einer
psychiatrischen anstalt untergebracht
werden laut staatsanwaltschaft gibt es
anhaltspunkte dafür dass er unter einer
paranoiden schizophrenie leidet der
29-jährige sei polizeilich mehrfach
bereits aufgefallen über politische oder
extremistische taten sei aber nichts
bekannt am abend haben berlins
regierende bürgermeisterin und der
hessische ministerpräsident rein blumen
für die opfer niedergelegt unter ihnen
war auch eine schulklasse aus hessen
die inflation hat sich entgegen früherer
hoffnungen nicht abgeschwächt sondern
ist sogar noch gestiegen nun stellt die
europäische zentralbank nach mehr als
einem jahrzehnt der extrem lockeren
geldpolitik die weichen für eine
zinserhöhung stephanie beckert was hat
die ezb vor die ezb hat heute das
historische signal gegeben
schuldenmachen wird wieder teurer das
gilt für verbraucher ebenso wie für
unternehmen und auch starten bei ihrer
sitzung im juli wird sie nun die
wichtigsten zinssätze erhöhen zuvor wird
sie ihr kaufprogramm für staatsanleihen
beenden die geldmenge wird also nicht
weiter aufgebläht vor allem eu staaten
konnten sich mit diesem programm
jahrelang günstig mit krediten versorgen
hier legt die ezb nun eine
geldpolitische vollbremsung hin und hoch
verschuldete eu staaten müssen nun
aufpassen denn zusätzliche
staatsschulden werden angesichts der
ohnehin durch krisen mächtig
angewachsenen schuldenstände gefährlich
wenn die zinsen steigen musste sich die
ezb bislang vorwerfen lassen das thema
inflation zu verharmlosen kamen heute
nun in amsterdam ganz neue deutliche
töne von ezb-chef christine lagarde die
inflation sei eine gewaltige
herausforderung für uns alle sie haben
sich zuletzt ausgebreitet und verstärkt
deshalb hebt die ezb ihre
inflationsprognose für dieses jahr
kräftig an und erwartet nun eine
durchschnittliche teuerungsrate von 6,8
prozent
denn allein die inflationstreiber
energie und lebensmittel sie dürften uns
verbraucher wohl noch länger
beschäftigen
stichwort verbraucher lässt sich schon
sagen welche folgen die entscheidung für
die verbraucher hierzulande hat also am
immobilienmarkt da ist die zinswende ja
bereits angekommen wäre ein häuschen
oder eine wohnung kaufen möchte der
sieht sich schon seit monaten mit
steigenden zinsen konfrontiert bauzinsen
haben sich seit dezember sogar
verdreifacht obwohl sie noch immer
natürlich historisch niedrig sind wann
es dagegen wieder sparzinsen geben wird
das ist ungewiss sparer werden sich wohl
noch gedulden müssen immerhin ist nun
aber bald schluss mit den negativzinsen
hier sind ja die meisten banken schon
mit blick auf die zinserhöhung dazu
übergegangen keine negativzinsen mehr
auf spareinlagen ihrer kunden zu
verlangen auch festverzinsliche
wertpapiere wie staatsanleihen werden
nun wieder interessanter für anleger
aktien dagegen verlieren an
attraktivität weil risikoreiche
abzulesen heute auch am deutschen
börsenbarometer der dax ging nämlich
direkt nach der ezb-entscheidung auf
tauchstation und schloss mit einem minus
von 1,7 prozent hier am finanzmarkt und
unter ökonomen wurden die beschlüsse der
ezb heute er verhalten aufgenommen zu
spät um die inflation einzufangen zu
homöopathisch um eine echte trendwende
in der geldpolitik zu bewirken stefanie
bareth vielen dank und in unserem heute
schon ein update ist das thema später
schwerpunkt mit der einschätzung einer
volkswirtin
an deutschlands großen seehäfen haben
heute tausende hafenarbeiter gestreikt
und damit nach gewerkschaftsangaben die
abfertigung von containerschiffen
erheblich verzögert von den warnstreiks
betroffen waren die häfen in hamburg
emden bremen bremerhaven und
wilhelmshaven
verdi will im tarifkonflikt der
forderung nach lohnerhöhungen und einem
inflationsausgleich für die rund 12.000
beschäftigten nachdruck verleihen morgen
soll eine neue verhandlungsrunde staaten
eines hat putins überfall auf die
ukraine der welt noch einmal vor augen
geführt wer atomwaffen hat kann sich
mehr erlauben als andere und wer keine
hat ist angreifbarer die
sicherheitsgarantien die die ukraine
einst erhielt als die in den neunziger
jahren ihrer atomwaffen aus der
sowjetzeit abgab waren am ende das
papier nicht wert dieser
anschauungsunterricht dürfte die
atomaren ambitionen von staaten wie
nordkorea oder iran noch mehr verstärkt
haben iran spitzt sich der konflikt
aktuell zu teheran hat angekündigt seine
urananreicherung zu intensivieren und
überwachungskameras der internationalen
atomenergie-behörde
abgeschaltet kamera mafia berichtet
der sprecher im iranischen
staatsfernsehen verkündet es offiziell
iran schaltet mehrere
überwachungskameras in seinen
atomanlagen ab dazu will teheran noch
schnellere zentrifugen zur
uran-anreicherung einsetzen der direktor
der internationalen atomenergiebehörde
in wien warnt der iran stehe kurz davor
ausreichend material für den bau einer
bombe zu haben
27 kameras in dem iran entfernt worden
wir befinden uns in einer sehr
angespannten lage
die verhandlungen für eine
wiederbelebung des atomdeals sind auf
einem tiefpunkt
es könnte gar der todesstoß sein wenn
die kameras nicht wieder installiert
würden so große iran kooperiere nicht
wollten die mitglieder der
internationalen atomenergiebehörde in
wien
auch hinsichtlich kürzlich gefundene
spuren angereicherten urans in drei
anlagen
iran hat längst die grenzen des von den
usa 2018 gekündigten atomdeals
überschritten teheran reichert uran über
die vereinbarte grenze von 3,67 prozent
an bis auf 60 prozent der weg zur bombe
mit 90 prozent ist nicht weit
außerdem hat teheran laut
atomenergiebehörde bisher 18 mal mehr
uran angereichert als erlaubt und auch
die zahl der zentrifugen übersteigt die
obergrenze israel wirft iran vertuschung
vor
ich halte hier beweise ihrer lügen in
den händen der iran hat geheime
dokumente der un-atomenergiebehörde
entwendet um herauszufinden was die
atomagentur in ihrer ansucht um
dementsprechend geschichten zu erfinden
um beweise für ihr nuklearmaterial zu
vernichten
der gottesstaat steht mit dem rücken zur
wand das land bräuchte eine einigung im
atomstreit
um die westlichen sanktionen loszuwerden
so protestieren die menschen seit tagen
gegen dramatische preiserhöhungen die
die wirtschaft belasten die jugend
ungewöhnlich offen
wir gehen hier kaputt wir haben wirklich
unsere hoffnung auf die zukunft und auf
ein leben hier aufgegeben
es ist eine katastrophe
wir kommen hier alle nicht mehr durch
egal was wir machen oder wo wir arbeiten
der ukraine krieg indes zu iranische
experten eröffnet dem sanktions
geplagten und isolierten iran auch
chancen den iran gehört zu den
spitzenreitern bei öl und gasvorkommen
weltweit
aufgrund der lage mit russland könnte
der westen auf iranisches öl und gas
angewiesen sein daher müsste er ein
interesse daran haben den atomkonflikt
mit iran und die sanktionen zu lösen so
könnte iran in den welt energiemarkt
eintreten und europa so den ökonomischen
druck nehmen
doch noch sind iran und der westen auf
konfrontationskurs
bundesverkehrsminister wissen hat sich
gegen das verkaufsverbot von neuwagen
mit verbrennungsmotoren ab 2035
ausgesprochen wird es das eu parlament
gestern gestimmt hat wissen plädierte
für verbrennungsmotoren über dieses
datum hinaus zuzulassen wenn sie
ausschließlich mit synthetischen
kraftstoffen
klimaneutral betrieben werden über das
votum des eu parlaments muss noch mit
den mitgliedsländern verhandelt werden
die ständige impfkommission hält vor dem
hintergrund der ungewöhnlichen häufung
von affen pocken infektionen impfungen
für bestimmte personengruppen für
sinnvoll und zwar für erwachsene die
engeren kontakt mit einem infizierten
hatten oder ein erhöhtes
ansteckungsrisiko haben einen
entsprechenden beschluss entwurf gab die
stiko heute bekannt in deutschland sind
nach angaben des robert koch instituts
mit stand heute 131
infektionen registriert worden
im süden spaniens bedroht ein waldbrand
teile der urlaubsregion costa del sol
mehr als 2000 menschen mussten in
sicherheit gebracht werden die flammen
lodern seit gestern in einem schwer
zugänglichen gebiet etwa 100 kilometer
westlich von malaga unter t kräfte sind
im einsatz drei feuerwehrleute wurden
verletzt hitze trockenheit und starke
winde erschweren die löscharbeiten warum
das feuer ausbrach ist noch unklar
das werk die fuge hatte neo rauch 2007
extra für seine ausstellung im new
yorker metropolitan museum of art
gemacht die kunst der fuge sozusagen ist
typisch für neo rauch gewaltig riesig
realistisch und zugleich so real und
traumhaft oder alptraumhaft und in ganz
eigener farbgebung doch es gibt auch
noch einen anderen neo rauch als den
maler solch monumentaler werke aktuell
ist eine umfassende sammlung seiner
grafiken und drucke zu sehen an einem
für ihn besonderen ort andreas weise und
tagen nicolas berichten
er ist einer der erfolgreichsten
deutschen maler der gegenwart
aushängeschild der neuen leipziger
schule neo rauch
doch das hier ist nicht bleibt sich und
es sind auch keine gemälde sein
grafisches werk drucke sind hier in
aschersleben zu sehen der ort an dem er
kindheit und jugend verbrachte der ihn
und seine arbeit bis heute prägt mich
interessiert dass das leben in den
urbanen zentren nicht jedenfalls nicht
als als mal da da finde ich kein
material das ich auf meinen leinwänden
oder auch meinen grafiken wir spiegeln
könnte sondern es sind eben diese
kleinstädtischen gegebenheiten
seit zehn jahren stellt neo rauch immer
wieder in aschersleben aus
dieses jahr die bisher umfassendste
präsentation seines grafischen schaffens
150 werke aus mehr als 30 jahren
dieses bild sein aktuellstes
weiß gekleidet mit seiner kelle
ausgestattet und der baut offenbar
luftschlösser
er schaffe ich auch luft ich weiß noch
vor mir muss zusehen dass ich sie
irgendwie in der balance halten
das ganze auf unsicherem grund
und zugleich scheint es mir eine
metapher zu sein für unsere existenz
schlechthin gerade im moment
das leben die älteste stadt sachsen
anhalts im vorharz aufgeblüht seit
landesgartenschau und internationaler
bauausstellung 2010 und die grafik
stiftung neo rauch der die meisten
grafiken auch tatsächlich gehören sorgt
für internationale aufmerksamkeit dass
der berühmteste sohn der stadt dagegen
ort über die grafik stiftung den weg zu
seiner heimatstadt wieder zurückgefunden
das natürlich ein großes glück das ist
da sind wir schon stolz drauf und die
sammlung soll weiter wachsen jedes jahr
im mai für mich ist es ein dauerhafter
antrieb geworden mich der grafik zu
widmen es ist der motor der mehr hinten
im nacken sitzt und der mir signalisiert
der mai rückt näher du musst wieder
einen grafiken machen oder vielleicht
sogar zwei besser noch drei es ist halt
eine ganz besondere verbindung des
leipzigers neo rauch zu aschersleben
[Musik]
das was man uns und jetzt wie vorhin
schon angekündigt erwartet sie maybrit
illner mit ihren gästen und um 00 45
gibt es dann unser heutigen update mit
gundula gause und uns morgen wieder
wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend es war einmal ein
tropensturm der hieß alex und ex alex
ist inzwischen hier vor island und
irland angekommen und zusammen mit dem
hoch schenk sorgen diese beiden druck
gebilde dafür dass es am wochenende bei
uns sehr sommerlich wird und dass die
temperaturen in süddeutschland an der 30
grad marke schrammen heute nacht fällt
noch etwas regen am alpenrand und auch
im bayerischen wald sonst es häufig
locker bewölkt klar oder es bildet sich
sogar mal etwas nebel die temperaturen
sinken auf werte zwischen 13 grad in der
lausitz und 6 grad in den westlichen
mittelgebirgen und steigen morgen über
tag auf 19 grad an der nordsee und auch
am alpenrand sonst werden 20 bis 26 grad
erreicht das wird ein sehr freundlicher
freitag häufig mit sonnenschein am
vormittag kann es hier niederbayern noch
etwas regnen und nachmittags im
äußersten westen ein paar regenschauer
geben in den nächsten tagen geht das
also sehr sommer nicht weiter und nur
über norddeutschland ziehen einige
schauer hinweg bei temperaturen von 19
bis 30 grad die neue woche startet dann
schon wieder wechselhafte und nicht mehr
ganz so warm und wie sie hier am trend
für ulm sehen können geht es mit diesen
temperaturen zwischen 20 und 25 grad
weiter dabei scheint häufig die sonne ab
und zu drohen allerdings auch schauer
und gewitter und mit diesen schönen
aussichten für das wochenende wünsche
ich ihnen jetzt schon mal einen schönen
abend